[Music]
do
instead it's totally fine to actually
just take the pawn
and uh then we can complete our
development and try to get that knight
to d5 let's castle
how can we try to get the knight to d5
could somebody chart for me a course
that this knight could potentially take
to land eventually on d5
second question how is bishop g4 often
met what move do we
like to play in these situations because
it's just a helpful move
and it forces him to sort of commit yes
h3 so first of all
let's make some luft for the king as
many of you guys are saying
92 would blunder the bishop but the idea
is knight a3 knight c4 and knight e3
and through e3 that's frankford airport
that's where you can fly to all the good
european destinations
but before you can fly to european
destinations you have to pass the
airport security
airport security's knight on f6 which
controls d5
how do we hypothetically get rid of that
knight and i probably
maybe should have played this move first
uh but we don't really have to get rid
of the knight but how could we get rid
of the knight
bingo the smithslav idea i've shown that
game a million times
bishop to g5 let's make this move first
because if i didn't play it
he'd probably go h6 okay what should we
do now do we take
do we drop it back are you paying
attention to what i just said
if yes then you should yeah knight c4
guess what we're trying to get the
knight over to d5 that's literally what
i'm trying to do
there's also a very nice tactical detail
which
he may allow us to demonstrate if he
plays v5 okay he doesn't
now there is a problem with knight e3
what we need to notice here ladies and
gentlemen is that the d3 bishop is a
type
uh two undefended piece and it's
defended by the queen the queen is
overloaded
so if knight e3 that severs the
connection between f3 and d3 he can take
on f3 and ruin the bishop
a ruin ruin the bishop he can ruin the
bishop but ruin the pawn structure is
what i meant to say
so what should we do yeah so g4 is
possible but it kind of weakens the king
side guys
what we actually can do here and this is
something which is
sort of not unique to a high level
you shouldn't be afraid to trade queens
to accomplish what you want the d5
square is still a sexy outpost
in the event of an end game that doesn't
change
uh so what bishop e2 accomplishes is now
we don't have to worry about
this knight being captured finally we
are ready to go to d5
and he prevents us from going to d5 but
in doing so he gets kind of passive
now let's deal with this standoff i'm
tired of this standoff so i'm going to
go knight to d2
because uh i'm just tired of him
constantly hanging
this over my head and we are going to
deal with this knight on e7 what this
creates is a situation where he is quite
passive
okay so he wants to take on e3 there's
not much i can do
to to stop him and i should now i want
to get this other knight to c4
the problem with knight c4 is that he's
going to play b5 and chase away the
knight
can i prepare knight c4 how can i
prepare knight c4
we can play a4 this is a kind of a
king's indian idea
i have to say this guy is also playing
tremendously well he's playing on a 2600
level
so i'm trying my best to nurture my
positional advantage
but uh this guy is is super super strong
what should we take with what should we
take with
we should actually take with the knight
exactly because now we have access to
the square his knight is basically
a slave to this square the queen can
take the knights place on c4
so this knight on e7 is pretty
immobilized
as soon as it moves well
as soon as it moves we're going to stick
our knight on d5 and we're actually
threatening a four
which he misses and uh the moment the
knight comes to d5
we basically win the game this isn't the
entire story because once he moves his
king
how much material do we actually win
here should we even take his queen
let's do some calculation that's
actually pretty poetic i have to say
and i am going to disable the alerts
during the speed run
yeah we get the exchange we take on c6
we take on z8 now
a lot of people here would notice the
pawn on b2 and they would probably go b3
but we don't actually have to go b3 we
have an even better move remember
that when you are up in exchange taking
off a pair of rooks
would be essentially squarely in a favor
but actually wait a second
on second thought guys i am wrong
because if rook d1 he is going to take
his rook
and then he's going to snap off the pawn
on b2 and what i missed
is that he's also going to be forking
the a pawn so let's actually we will go
b3
because he wins just a little too many
pawns there and i'm
afraid that even in the event of a rook
trade we won't have any puns
left so you know okay knight a5
now that uh knight takes b3 doesn't
actually come
with a fork uh we can go ahead and play
rook to d1
rook after d1 would also be fine
now if he takes on b3 yeah so he goes
here how should we follow up
uh we have now gained the defile but we
need to
squeeze the most out of that d file by
playing rook to d7 we are making contact
with this
type 2 undefended pawn the knight is
protecting it which means that b4
is a good move but let's instead start
just taking all of his pawns
here's one pawn here's another one we
are now up upon end of the exchange and
our
ultimate long-term plan if he allows it
if he doesn't go rook to d8
if he does uh we will deal with that but
where should this work go
yeah piggy's on the seventh stack up
that seventh ring that is such a
typical endgame idea and it's such a
strong one because we are going to win
this fun
we are going to win the game okay
um so pretty smooth and a nice
positional game
so d6 he kind of pre-moved i don't think
he expected c3
uh and this gives white a very nice
center we've sort of talked about this
now at this level you can see that these
guys they
they um they make very reasonable moves
right uh at an earlier
rating c takes d4 was often
the move that uh that was played against
us hey montana chess
and as you guys know the problem with
this is it gives the b1 knight this e3
square it's very cooperative at this
level
you know they strike in the center they
don't back down knight f3 knight c6
and i i take on c5 so the key
the key property of this position that
gives white that slight but stable
advantage
is that d5 square which is going to be a
perpetual weakness there is no
equivalent weakness on d4
because i have a pawn on c3 that's
protecting that um
so ultimately here is where i charted
the chorus for the knight
knight a3 knight c4 and 93 knight d5
now you guys might look at this and say
well that's like four moves i've talked
about the three move rule
which is a good way to estimate whether
an idea you have is realistic if it
takes three moves or longer
i often claim that the idea is
unrealistic but you need to take that
with a very serious grain of salt i'm
not saying that i'm literally putting my
head down
and i'm going to make these moves in
succession what i'm talking about is an
ultimate goal not a plan
where i make one move after the other
move regardless of what he does
so what we see in practice is i play
knight a3 then i play bishop g5 and take
his knight out
right then i play knight c4 i don't even
play 93 i'm making these moves
uh in a very measured fashion so knight
e3 bishop takes f3 allow or forces me to
play gf
and and ruin my structure uh by the way
the nice detail
if he goes b5 this may seem very nasty
because after knight e3 uh
what move does he now have
so if you've been paying attention to
what i just said
not c4 c4 is not dangerous guys before
he's not dangerous don't make a move
just because it threatens a piece
all right i don't want to see that
bishop b2 you know better
c4 is tempting don't fall for temptation
in fact
this becomes a very weak pawn chain uh
which white can undermine with a4
undermining the b5 pawn the move is
bishop takes f3
and here white has a very sexy response
what's uh how do we find this move we
put on our sam
shanklin hats our sam glen hats tell us
well if a move is impossible we first
ask ourselves what happens if i do it
anyway
what happens if i do it anyway you must
ask yourself that question you must
allow yourself
to look at certain positions and if you
look at those positions and you have a
better chance
of not ruling stuff out instinctually
play tao for president
you play queen f3 anyway b5 pawn blocks
the pathway back of the queen
rook 81 traps the queen look at that
so i saw that which is why knight c4 was
justified and the queen is trapped
black is busted if he goes knight c4 you
can simply take the knight and nothing
has changed
so anyways that's what would have
happened if b5
now you might ask well what's why can't
we do this anyway here
well the pawn is on b7 which means the
queen can escape so it's very important
not to generalize that's why we played
bishop b2
and i think black probably should have
gone for the end game i think the end
game would have lessened to blacks load
a little bit
queen c7 93 97 i asked myself what
happens if i do it anyway it only takes
one second
my claim to you guys is that once you
consider queen f3 and you look at this
position
you don't need a grand master to find
rook 81 okay everybody can see rock81
uh given this position it's just a
matter of
so i would divide tactical difficulty
into two different categories
category one is like stuff that is hard
to
let me let me think about how to
formulate this
category one is stuff that is hard to
calculate
so it's a move that everybody sees like
a sacrifice
but it leads to very chaotic uh
contin at least to a very chaotic
continuation and you have to calculate
that and it's hard
category two are things that are hard to
see
but not hard to calculate it's like a
venn diagram okay hard to calculate r to
see and then there's middle of the venn
diagram which is both
and that's the kinds of problems that
grandmaster solved this
is easy to calculate but very hard to
see there's actually
basically nothing to calculate and you
have to try to train both of these
skills if that makes sense
okay so bishop b2 knight e3
now we go knight d2 a4 to prepare knight
c4
white is slightly better there's nothing
huge about white's advantage
but it's an unpleasant position and he
finally buckles this is my point when
you apply pressure on your opponent for
so long
he's going to buckle rook d2 would be a
good move forcing me to play the
relatively passive rook b1
and black should be able to hold a draw
with a couple of
accurate moves this is probably already
close to equal
um and uh he plays knight c8 allowing
knight d5
here what should black have done instead
of knight b6
well how do i determine who is better
basically the position is symmetrical
with the exception of the d5 square
so white's slightly better chess dojo
live another raid 59
welcome everybody we are doing this
speed run
yeah rookie or uh you could also play
king ha
another two category thing is a threat
can be dealt with
by removing the symptoms or by removing
the cause or ki removes the symptoms
right e7 is defended but king h8
would remove the cause i actually prefer
this move you often want to remove the
cause
because rookie 8 actually basically ties
down your rook
to a passive existence of that although
in this particular case it doesn't
really matter
and then black can play knight p6 to
trade the knights off or knight d6 to
chase the queen away instead of course
knight knight uh c8 knight b6 is a
blunder
it doesn't drop the queen but it does
drop the exchange and the rest is
very very straightforward any questions
that was a pretty straightforward game
uh our opponent was good but you know we
didn't do anything
we didn't reinvent the wheel just uh
sort of
typical rudimentary positional
principles were
uh rehearsed looks like everybody is
pretty clear on what we did
excellent let's continue
okay jimmy fallon won 2400 okay so let's
go e4
let's go e4
this guy is good e5 okay so here we're
going to play my real openings
i am going to play the rye lopez now i'm
going to play my real openings i mean
because this these guys are serious
uh so so i'm going to play my real
openings okay so d6 is fine
that is called the steinitz variation
and white should not particularly change
the way that i play uh we already know
that well d6 creates
a pin so from a logical perspective what
would be a good way
to exploit that pin would be to open up
the position with what move
we know that the right lopez there's two
main ways to play we can play c3 to
prepare d4
but the immediate d4 is also perfectly
good and after e takes d4
knight takes d4 we exploit the fact that
the knight can move now a very good move
in this position
is actually to take the knight this is a
hard move to understand you guys might
be like wait a minute isn't the whole
the whole point to like leave the night
there and after the game i'll explain
the rationale behind this move basically
this softens up the e5
pawn so uh it eventually if i play this
correctly will force black
into taking on d4 and yielding
a lot of the center so i'm going to
castle if he takes on e4
he opens up the e file and i'm going to
get a big initiative uh
once that bishop appears on e4 okay so
i'm going to take it
he does take anyway okay
and how do we very simple move
how do we attack this bishop and make a
general
improving move remember that we can take
on e5 later to reclaim the pawn but we
don't need to rush with that we play
rookie one
and now the thing is we're attacking
this pawn and we're we're pinning him i
feel like white is better here
okay so we have several things that we
can take it's like a buffet
um what should we capture here what
should we start by capturing
and there are several possibilities but
the e5 pawn isn't going anywhere because
my advice to you guys see here i think a
lot of you guys are falling into
a slightly faulty pattern of thinking
this is the pawn i actually want to
capture because e5 is not
going anywhere he is not going to play e
takes d4
because that disastrously opens up the e
file and so now we can play d takes e5
obviously i'm not going to take again
because of the back rank mate but the
reason why it is better here
is because his pawn structure on the
queen side is quite ruined and my pieces
are very active
but we have to be very careful about how
we follow this up if we play bishop e3
mindlessly developing the bishop we
allow rook b8
and he wins the b2 pawn so one
possibility is to fianchetto with b3
but that weakens all of these dark
squares i don't really want to do that
the other thing that we can do in such
positions
is is of course just to move move the
queen
uh we're going to move it to a nice
centralized location we are also
threatening to take on e5
white is slightly better i'm not winning
but i have a very pleasant position
let's speed up our pace of play a little
bit then we can develop our bishop and
bring a rook into the game
again i i hope that people are more or
less understanding my play
i'm not doing anything crazy
okay so rook beat is a good move um if
i guess what he's trying to do is bait
me into taking the pawn
what does black have in the event of
queen takes e5 this pawn is actually
kind of like an umbrella or it's a it's
a barricade that is separating his
pieces from from mine he's got bishop f6
and his bishop opens up
the b coupon is lost i don't want to
allow any of that
so i actually well b3 he maybe has
bishop to b4 and then bishop to c3
driving the bishop in so what i'm going
to do here is go c3
i am going to control the b4 square so
his row can't go there and i'm also
going to reinforce the thread of queen
takes e5
because once i take and he goes bishop
f6 the bishop as we know is biting on
granite
yeah i'm not sure why he allows me to
take but i'm just going to call his
bluff here
and now i'm just going to be up a pawn
in the end game let's see if i can
convert it into a win
uh queen takes c5 this the queen d6 was
a bad move because now
he well he can't avoid the queen trait
actually he can move his queen away
but he doesn't uh so rook takes c5
rookie
that's a good move he's he's heading for
d1 and we need to be careful because if
we move the bishop out once again he has
bishop f6
uh the rook has to move and and then
rook takes b2
comes with great effect so we shouldn't
panic here we we simply need to target
the cause of the threat right
we can go king f1 that's a nice way to
defend against rook d1 if rook d1 check
we simply drop a rook back and we're
going to do that anyway to stop rook t1
and we're fine for the time being what's
challenging here about white's position
is untangling our queen side if we
untangle our queen side
we are going to be not completely
winning but
we're going to be well on the way to
winning the game so
rook b1 is one idea to open up the
bishop what is the problem with rook b1
yeah we should have gone rookie two
we're actually going yeah bishop takes
e3 so we're actually going to try rookie
two here
and the point of this is of course to
bring the bishop out if he goes rookie
one check which he should do
but let's see if he finds this then i'm
going to come back to e1
i'm just asking him to find this one
move and then we repeat the position
and i'm going to try to find an
alternate method but right now he's not
playing rook d1 so
maybe he's hesitating for whatever
reason
if anything yeah he does go rook to d1
so we have to unfortunately repeat the
position
and um i'm going to show you a five-head
idea if he drops his rook back which he
probably will because training rooks is
in white's favor we are up a pawn i'm
going to show you guys prepare for a
five-head
idea oh he takes okay so that is a
little bit odd to me
what i think he's trying to do here is
what he's trying to say is now i can't
get the bishop out but
what he has forgotten is that i now have
a little piece called a king and the
king
can get stuff done it absolutely can get
stuff done
what do i mean by that how can it get
stuff done where can the king go
uh in the name of liberating the bishop
from c1 the king of course goes to this
nice little
c2 square then the bishop comes out
finally we can
complete our development we can bring
the rook out and we can convert
our extra pawn we do not need to defend
h2
because of the move g3 bobby fischer
boris baskey but
at the same time in okay we'll go rook
to
at some point i want to move that h-bond
because i don't want to keep having to
deal with this
this is something that a lot of people
don't understand like why are you
defending the pawn if you just said he
can't take it yes he can't take it
but does it make sense that i don't want
to have to deal with this all the time
so now a4 what this move accomplishes is
it fixes the weakness
the pawn on a5 is on a dark square i
want you guys to pay very careful
attention to that and guess what
he now allows us to exploit this
weakness in textbook fashion
what should we do should we take the
rook and if we do take the rook
why what will be our follow-up yeah of
course we take the rook
and we have bishop b6 that is why we
played a4 the pawn is immobilized
and he has a terrible choice he can go
bishop c7 and the pawn end game is of
course completely lost
but so is the bishop end game i'm gonna
be up two pawns both of them on the
queen side of the game is over
so he really collapsed here quite
quickly
um okay so takes on on a5 he's probably
gonna go here
and try to corner my bishop but the
bishop has an escape route via b4
okay now uh the win is a very very
simple matter
of pushing pushing my pawns but uh
you always hear the advice be patient in
the end game what that really means is
you want to make all the necessary
improvements first
what kind of improvement can you make
before pushing the pawns
so like yeah so let's bring the king out
first so the king can supervise the
progress of the pawns we don't need to
worry about the king side
because the pawns are symmetrical we
need to watch for a pawn break
but by and large we don't need to do
anything now even
we even here we can make an improvement
before pushing the pawns up
we can reposition this bishop to which
square
yeah bishop b4 bishop c5 is right
bishop b4 bishop c5 is right and only
then
when all of these necessary improvements
have been made
did you guys not see me play bullet
against min 30 seconds is an eternity
folks
you are in the hands of a professional
everybody take a deep breath we are we
will be just fine
trust me on this one we will be just
fine we go king c5 to force him to take
the pawn
then we are going to reposition our king
to d5 and
finally we are going to bring the other
pawn up to c4
c5 c6 and we are going to win
do not try this okay so i should have
taken the pawn but it doesn't matter
because
everything is protected just don't
pre-move we can actually pre-move c6
check because it is a check but that is
the only thing we do not pre-move bc app
or tampering with v6
and now we can transition into a pawn
end game but first let's play b6
now it's important here to notice the
bishop on f4 okay bishop c7
bc check and now we bring our king in
and we are going to cause zugzwang
and the game is over
so f4 we can just immobilize his fonts
first that's fine also
okay check now what move should we make
in this position
how do we cop how do we force zooxvon
what do we do
okay we move the bishop yeah good job i
just wanted one person to answer this
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
move the bishop to g5
in order to avoid the possibility of
stalemate
that's actually a very important little
trick
right just make sure the bishop doesn't
control any possible squares
okay are you guys a little bit convinced
that everything was under control
yeah we're fine uh it it's cosmetically
close but it really isn't close i i know
how much time i need to and what you
guys need to understand is i've played
for so long
that i know how much time i need to win
these positions i know that i'm going to
win this with an abundance
of time on my clock i'm not trying to
rub it in anyone's face
okay so this was a rye lopez
and the first kind of surprising move is
bishop takes c6 right
but i think it actually isn't as
surprising as i'm making it out to be we
are simply weakening
the e5 pawn we're trying to get him to
take on d4 which of course gives me
a much better slice of the center okay
and and this is just a super active
position
uh once he goes knight f6 you can get
this bishop out to g5 white is slightly
better
that's just bottom line what we're
aiming for here is a slightly better
position
oh my god and there we go
jer jerky sminion with 20
are you kidding me in astral 96 throwing
in a sub there
my lands girl the 4 am
hype is unreal 4 20 gifted sums by jerky
simon
kgb operative throwing in his sub as
well
and we are on the way back to magic
thank you so much appreciate it jerky
simon
uh you're the man and and the damn girl
also
so thank you thank you appreciate it
okay so uh once this happens
he goes knight f6 and we castle does
this part of the game make sense guys
we're actually kind of semi sacrificing
the fun for
an initiative right we are pushing him
around he's not developed
so i know that i'm going to win back the
pawn worst comes to worst
this is not you know i'm not taking a
big risk here or i'm sacrificing a pawn
oh my god
ruling snow i know that i'm going to win
back e5
okay so bishop takes f3 queen takes f3
bishop b7 now
a lot of you guys wanted to take on e5
and there is a
well this might transpose into the game
if he castles
i can take on b7 this is literally the
game position
however there was a move that deterred
me from playing d takes e5 specifically
could anybody tell me what move i am
referring to
it's just a concrete thing right the
move d5
and he intercepts my queen's access to
b7 and he keeps the position closed we
do not want the position to be closed
because we have the initiative
maybe i can play e6 here but um how can
black respond
to this position on the topic of not
panicking keep a cool head when you see
a move like this because sometimes you
don't really have to do anything crazy
at all
thank you jared lefty look at these subs
that's what we like to see we just
castle because we simultaneously defend
the pawn and black is completely fine
here in fact black might be better after
c6
okay so that's the reason i didn't play
de i took on b7
and uh well e takes d4 is horrible for a
variety of reasons
um king russo asks what if he played f4
when the bishop was on e4 that's a great
question
if he had played f5 ding ding ding ding
ding ding
this sets the alarm bells off in my head
because this weakens his king side even
further and guess what
he's not he hasn't developed his bishop
so
if i can get this bishop out of e4 then
i'm gonna have a direct artery to his
king
that's not going to end well for for uh
for black so knight g5 is a typical
attacking move
and um and now i can i can take on e5
and this just looks i mean this looks
absolutely devastating
um well quicker wrote in in which
position
can he take on d4 because his bishop is
hanging here and
here he's pinned so he he never could
capture on d4 oh oh you mean here
yeah so so this opens up the e5 i mean
this move looks good
um although he's got f6 there you can
give a check force the king back i mean
why can't just do nothing at all just
develop his pieces and i've got full
compensation thank you derpy ebola for
the tier one
okay whoops sorry my bad so he castles
we take
and we drop the queen back to e4 okay we
drop the queen back to e4
centralizing it getting it out of the
line of fire of the rook
and now uh the calm stage of the game we
go c3
uh in order to protect the b4 square and
the d4 square
this pawn is is kind of a nice nice
little pawn
and the follow-up move would have
probably been to play b3 and then
developing the bishop
so queen d6 is a big mistake he just i
think he forgot the pawn was hanging he
should have defended it
he should have played bishop f6 or
whatever bishop d6
he should have defended the pawn and
then he makes another mistake by trading
queens
black is a very clever way of avoiding
the queen trade here who can tell me
what it is i mentioned it during the
game
but i didn't say a specific move the way
that you need to find this specific move
is once again to realize that when the
bishop is on c1
white needs to worry about the back rank
okay
um and what that means is you could also
think of the rook on e1 being a type 2
undefended piece
so the queen could just slide on over to
c6 in fact even queen d7 is good
and that's a vicious trap because after
rookie a black wins the queen you cannot
move the queen due to back rank
checkmate
that is why um if you have a chance to
play a move like h3 in certain positions
that's a good idea
because of tactics like these does that
make sense so he should have at least
kept the queens on the board
so takes takes this uh brings the game
into an end game we go king f1
to prepare rookie one against rook d1
um now the five head move if he didn't
trade brooks okay so let's say that he
would have brought his rook back to d8
repeating the position
let me guide you guys through i'm not
saying this is an amazing move i'm just
saying it's a nice
idea it's an elegant idea now the bottom
line is
i want to move the bishop out fact one
let's bring everybody on board with the
fact that we want to bring does that
make sense the reason i want to bring
the bishop out is because i need to
complete my development to win this game
now we have already determined that
defending the pawn on b2
opens up another tactic with bishop
takes c3
and you cannot move the bishop out
directly because you drop b2 and then
you drop c3 etc
so the question i ask myself is do i
have any other methods
of defending the b2 pawn so that i can
bring the bishop
out we already know that rookie 2 has
been tried and it failed
to the check so that's where this idea
comes from
you just need to apply some creativity
thong me
look at you okay who else can find well
king e2
the problem is the king can't walk to c2
because there's a force field on the d
file b3 doesn't work because it drops c3
a4 is the correct move but the idea is
to put the rook on a2
that is the ultimate idea rook a2 in
order to liberate the bishop
okay you can put the rook on a2 now
isn't the rook passive there i hear you
guys a little
cringe horrible temporarily
the rook's not going to stay on a2
eventually i'm going to find a way to
once the bishop moves out i'm going to
have the resources necessary
to somehow defend the pawn again and
then free up the rook
but it's all about the priorities here
it's okay to make an ugly looking move
as long as you are fulfilling a priority
well a4 gives the rook a little bit more
space
maybe you'll need the a3 square that's
all there is to it
okay um so that's the bottom line
idea i can swear i saw a game like this
um
i can swear that i saw a a uh
a game like this before and in general
um
this notion of of defending something uh
in order to
in order to move a piece out of the way
is a a relatively common trope actually
oh i do remember the game let me just
find the game that i'm referencing here
i recently gave uh to my students
a problem it's it's a completely
different position but
it's a similar concept that i think some
of you guys should
file away in your sort of um
mental rolodex of positional ideas the
notion of
wanting to play a move and not being
able to play it because something is
going to be hanging
right some pawn is going to be left
hanging for example and so you simply
um you make a contract with one of your
pieces and you say look peace
look rook look knight i am going to
force you to do something unglamorous
but i promise
um eventually you're going to be freed
from this task once we do what we need
to do
okay here's a good example of that and
this this dovetails back into another
concept of
static versus dynamic uh concepts in
chess something that is dynamic is
temporary and likely to change something
that is static
is likely to stay the same piece
placement is generally quite
dynamic you can change the way a piece
uh
sits on the board pretty quickly so you
don't need to worry about a piece being
passive
uh for a short duration of time that's
that's that's okay
okay so this position right anderson
against vagany and anderson one of the
strongest positional players of all time
now when we look at this position who is
better and why
uh we are looking at it from white's
perspective so well white is better why
is white better what are the weaknesses
of black's position
simple question i'm not looking for any
any rocket science answers just look at
the position
i'm looking for two things very
specifically
and you guys got one after the other so
the d5 hole
and as so often happens the d6 pawn
is also weak backward pawn and the space
in front of it
now there is a problem we have a way to
occupy this square
and that is to play knight d5 how should
we
attack this one if we wanted to attack
the pawn on d6 what seems to be a pretty
obvious way
to immediately threaten that pawn
well e5 just blunders the pawn yeah
knight b5 bishop f4 blunt is the bishop
knight controls the square knight b5
there is a problem with both of these
moves both the moves knight b5 and
knight d5
run into the same problem what is that
problem not a hard question guys just
look
at the position yeah b2 is hanging and
so anderson
said aha okay wait a second i need to
defend b2
but wait whoa whoa i know a lot of you
are going to start thinking b3
this is the 2200 move b3 is a good move
but that's not the grand master old
anderson move the grand master move
is while you are at it you prepare
another idea and the move
beautiful rook c2 rook c2 is a very
strong positional move
why is it so good because you're
simultaneously defending the pawn of two
and you are also preparing to move the
rook onto d2
not insane but very nice idea and the
funny thing is
uh vaganyon played a6 to stop knight b5
anderson played rook d2
and vaganyan played knight d4 to plug
the hole on the defile and anderson
actually just
sacks the exchange because he's got a
pawn for the exchange and this pawn is
going to fall it falls on the next move
he's got two puns for the exchange
and the knight comes into d5 white's got
a massive position and you won the game
in the end
okay so a couple of lessons here and
and the second among them is that when
you have an idea you want to try to find
the best execution for it
the best execution often involves
preparing with the
prophylactic move also an active idea
um would you be worried about bishop c3
no
because that gives away the fiance
bishop and the pawn on c3
a great example of double pawns being
good covers the d4 square so
literally you cannot defend d6 you're
just busted here
does that make sense uh so that's an
echo of the concept we applied in in in
the speedrun game of course completely
different but
hopefully you can see the similarity um
okay so he he goes he he took the rook
which is just
bad and now we get the king to c2 same
idea free up the bishop
and the rest is very simple i mean he
shouldn't have gone rook d7 that
accelerates his defeat
completely overblown if he did not go
rook d7
what would be the plan of victory in
this position and
we have discussed this time and time
again in these kinds of end games
we simply need to identify uh the
potential to create a past pawn and then
we need to find the best way to do it
we have two good ways to create this
past fun the best
well bishop d4 i'm actually not a huge
fan of because this bishop on e3 guys is
a huge asset
this bishop on e3 could not only help
create a past pawn but it could also
help attack this pawn
so i like bishop c5 to prepare b4
also this bishop paves the way for the
pawn because once the pawn reaches a6
hey bishop's going to cover that a7
square and we're going to be able to
play a 7.
trading more pieces is not always good
that is the point i have made
from the very beginning of my speed run
the fact that
um the fact that
okay when you're up a pawn or up a piece
most trades are going to be good
but once you've traded down to an end
game do not just blindly continue to
continue to trade
um you see what i'm saying here peace
can often be super valuable
okay um and after rook d7 we take we win
the pawn and the game is over if he
he had done bishop c7 then we've simply
take and go before
completely winning pawn end game any
questions about this game
we played many more moves but he could
have resigned here we made
all of oh that's from goodwill honda we
we made all of the necessary
improvements
and we pushed the pawn how about them
apples
okay eugene looks like what is the best
defense against the rue lopez
yeah the berlin is good a6 is the main
move
and then you get the main line with
knight f6 and bishop b7 that's sort of
the
i've won about when he brought the rook
to absolutely mr boyd
i'm all ears mr boyd he brought the rook
down in this position i mean he brought
the rook down several times
i assume you mean here uh what's the
question
oh there we go could he have brought the
other rook oh could he have brought the
other rook to defend
yes he could have that's not a bad move
but the thing is i can just move my
bishop out
and the rook on d1 is now under fire
from both rooks
which means that he must now
either [ __ ] or get off the pot both of
which are perfectly good scenarios
uh if he takes the rook then we do what
we want if he moves the rook away then
that's that's great as well
i think that's a good expression to
capture to capture the situation
blackstroke is in
um anyways
[Music]